What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity and welcome to another episode
of Challenge Pongfinity!
This is the series where YOU challenge US
with your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
We will go through all of your comments, pick
the most creative ones and make a video out
of them.
If your idea gets picked, we will feature
it and give it a shout out.
So make sure to leave your ideas in the comment-section below!
Marek Kowalski wants us to play 10 consecutive
shots with the edge of the racket.
Let's see how many we can get.
Kanav Chaudhri wants us to do 5 around the
net shots, let's do it!
That's how you do it.
Rupam DAGA wants us to play table tennis using
a knife!
Let's see how well we can slice with this
one.
Thanks Nickbrine Gaming, I have my racket
taped to my foot and I will try to go around
the net with it.
Thanks for watching guys!
If you enjoyed the video leave it a thumbs
up and if you are new to the channel subscribe
right here.
And watch the previous episodes here.
Until next time!